وصف الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس مديريه
الاحتجاجات بالاعداء مؤكدا مواصله العمل
على الجبهات كافه لافشال كل ما يحاك ضد
بلاده واضاف رئيسي خلال لقائه مسؤولين في
المجلس الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه بايران ان
من وصفهم بالاعداء يرتكبون اخطاء
استراتيجيه لانهم لا يعرفون الاوضاع في
البلاد بشكل صحيح
لانهم لا يدركون الاوضاع بشكل صحيح نتيجه
وجودهم في افغانستان عاما يدعونا انه
يمتلكون القوه الاعلاميه والاستخباراتيه
لكن نتيجه التدخلهم في افغانستان لم تكن
سوا الحرب واراقه الدماء والفشل اعماله
الشعب التي شهدتها البلاد من صنع الاعداء
ويجب التعامل معها من الجهه الامنيه
والثقافيه المسؤولون في الجهات الامنيه
يتعاملنا مع الملفات مستقرا وسنواصل هذا
المسار للتعزيز الامن الجهات والثقافيه
والاقتصاديه وايضا يجب ان تتعامل مع هذا
الملف من جانبها وهذا امر ضروري